- The 17-year-old who video recorded
George Floyd's murder is going to receive
an honorary Pulitzer Prize,
and I think this is a great development.
So many people felt powerless in the face
of what was happening to
George Floyd and others,
and Darnella Frazier,
who was only 17 at the time,
stood her ground and recorded things.
She was walking home with
her nine-year-old cousin
when she had the bravery to sit there
and record everything happening.
Of course, many people
wanted to intervene,
but the fact of the
matter is if you intervene
in a situation like that,
you might be charged with
obstruction of justice
or assaulting a police
officer, and it's not fair,
but those are the rules.
And what people can do is
when they see something
that might be suspicious, it's not clear,
simply record the police
or record the activity.
That's what you can do
as a citizen to prevent
these kinds of things from
happening in the future.
It's sad but true but the
conviction of Derek Chauvin
probably wouldn't have happened
without the video evidence,
and we should be encouraging
citizen journalists like this,
as much as we can.